-Welcome back, everybody.
We're hanging out with
three-time Grammy-winning
music superstar,
my co-host for tonight, the one
and only, Megan Thee Stallion.
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"Traumazine." "Traumazine"
is out at midnight tonight.
And we have a special guest
appearing.
-Yes, 4oe!
-4oe! Welcome!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-He's like, "What's happening?
What's all these people?"
-4oe, look over there.
Look at the camera.
-Who's that, 4oe?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Who is that, 4oe? Who is that?
-He's so cute.
-He's still there.
He's like, "Who is that?"
[ Laughter ]
-He's a natural.
Thank you for being here.
Thanks for doing this.
I appreciate it.
Do you have any questions
you want to ask me while you're
here 'cause you're co-hosting?
-Okay. So, the only question
that I really had was,
are you a fan of Hot Cheetos?
-Of course.
-Okay.
So, apparently, this is
like a thing
that I've only ever seen
in Houston happen.
We eat Hot Cheetos
but inside of pickles.
-I've never --
-Y'all have never done that
before?
-Has anybody done that?
Hot Cheetos inside?
-Inside of a pickle.
-Do we have one?
-So, we got these.
-Oh, my gosh.
-It's all gourmet.
-Dude, look at you.
The best co-host ever.
-This one's going to be mine.
And this one's for you.
-Wait, look at this.
-Yes.
-Now, this really is a thing?
Did you invent this?
-No, I promise, as a kid --
We can cheers it.
-Cheers.
-Ting.
-And just bite it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey, I love it.
-I wouldn't lie to you.
-I love that you just introduced
me to something awesome.
Thank you so much, pal.
-Where are you going?
-I'm going to do that.
4oe, sorry, I couldn't save
anything for you.
-Let me take a sip of this water
before 4oe does.
-That is --
Is this mike on?
[ Dog breathing ]
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, usually 4oe shakes his
head like "No,"
when he doesn't like something.
He's just being shy tonight.
-I like that.
-I'm like, "4oe, do you want
some vegetables"
and he'll be like...
-No, can I see if he'll sit
and give me his paw?
-Yeah. Oh, he will.
He gives high fives.
-Pretty cute if he'll do it.
Ready?
4oe, 4oe, sit.
That's it, bud.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Such a good dog!
-Come on, that dog is talented.
Come on.
He's so cute.
-That's my bestie.
-He sits and gives a high five.
Speaking of Hot Cheetos, though,
is it true Jay-Z
gave you a plate of Hot Cheetos
when he first signed you?
-Yes. Okay, so, everybody
on the entire planet knows
I'm like Miss Hot Cheetos.
Even before I got a deal with
Hot Cheetos.
I'm just obsessed with
I would eat them for breakfast
in like middle school.
So I feel like always on my
rider there's Hot Cheetos.
Anytime I come in a room,
this room better be full of
Hot Cheetos.
So I was in my meeting.
I was just about to sign with
Roc Nation.
I hadn't signed my deal yet,
but I'm in the meeting
and I'm talking and everybody's
like, "Yeah, okay,
the boss is about to come in,"
and I'm like, "Who?"
And I look and it's Jay-Z.
And I'm like, "Uh!
Now Jay-Z in my meeting?"
-You didn't know
he was gonna be there?
-No, and it was like platters of
Hot Cheetos.
And I was like, "Oh, I was gonna
sign anyway, but yes!"
[ Laughter ]
That's how you do it.
-"Came right into my world."
I just want to say some things
that you've done since last time
you've been on the show, okay.
You've won three Grammys,
by the way. Congratulations.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I loved it.
Best New Artist, Best Rap Song,
Best Rap Performance.
You were named
top female rap artist
at the Billboard Music Awards
two years in a row, bud.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You had multiple-platinum hit
songs with Cardi B,
seven times, by the way,
platinum.
-It's almost diamond.
-Wow, diamond.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's amazing.
You graduated college.
-Whoo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And then you became
the first female rapper ever
to perform at the Oscars.
Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay.
-What did that feel like?
-So, technically, Queen Latifah
is the first female rapper
to perform at the Oscars ever,
but she didn't perform
a rap song.
So I'm the first female rapper
to perform a rap song.
-Ah, that's good.
-Which is still really big.
-No, no, no, that's history.
-That's history.
That was the first time that had
ever happened in life.
And what's even more cool about
it is right before
I went on stage, I had no idea
Queen Latifah was there.
So right before I went on stage,
I'm like backstage,
and I'm really nervous because
oh, my gosh, everybody in
Hollywood that's important
is in this one room
and they all about
to be looking at me.
But Queen Latifah is in the back
and I'm like looking down
at my feet like, "Okay, Megan,
don't forget your lines."
And I look up and it's
Queen Latifah! And I'm like --
[ Laughter ]
-You're like, "I'm nervous.
What do I do?"
-Lord, how do you add
more pressure on to
what I'm about to do right now?
Boom, Queen Latifah is in here.
-She's right there.
So, she's like -- you know like
the Spider-Man meme --
We both had on the same color
too, and people say
me and Queen Latifah look alike,
so I was just like,
"Oh, my gosh, yes, my girl,"
and she's like,
"Okay, I was about to leave,
but actually,
because you here, you're about
to perform, I'm about to stay.
So I was like, "Oh, yes!"
-Yeah, there's no one cooler.
-Nobody cooler than
Queen Latifah.
-She's the greatest. Here's
you two right here backstage.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love you, Latifah.
She's the greatest.
And that was awesome.
I also saw a photo you got with
Bill Murray
at one of the Oscar parties.
-Yes.
-I was like, "Do you know Bill?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
You know Bill?
-I was gonna make sure
I knew him that day.
-Yeah, exactly.
"I need a picture with Bill."
-It was so random. I was like by
Tracee Ellis Ross,
Chloe Bailey, a bunch of other
cool people,
and Bill Murray is just walking
by and I'm like...
"Y'all, I'mma get this picture
with Bill Murray.
I'mma be right back."
-He's the best, man.
-I just ran up on him.
I'm like, "Bill Murray, can I
take a picture?"
I don't know if he knew
who I was.
-Yeah, he does.
-Where you going?
-He's alright.
[ Laughter ]
-He's like, "I'm out.
Cut the check."
-Yeah, he's gonna go --
Bill Murray's in the hallway.
He's gonna go take a picture
with Bill.
Can we talk about "Traumazine"?
-Yes.
-This is a big deal.
-This is a huge deal.
-This is out at midnight.
This is out basically right now.
-Yes.
-It's out.
-It's out!
-You've been teasing the album
for a while now.
It's finally out. How do you
know when an album's ready?
-I feel like it just feels good.
Like, I literally -- This is
the longest time I've ever taken
to record an album.
Like, I had at least 50 songs
recorded for this.
-Oh, my gosh.
-And we only chose 18.
-How do you do that?
-It was hard because --
As an artist sometimes, like,
your label can kind of try to
control you and tell you
what to do. Like...
And they kind of pick your songs
for you.
But I feel like I made it
a point to write all songs
that I loved and I liked
and that meant something to me
so out of however many songs
I wrote,
all of them feel good to me.
-Yeah, so you could
put out an album of 50.
-Right.
I could put all 50 of
those songs
and they still mean
something to me.
-So where do those other songs
go, in the vault?
-They go in the vault
but I think -- I'll do stuff
like release mix tapes
and things like that
just to keep my hotties
on their toes, like,
"Hey, I'mma about to drop
something."
-You said this is
your most personal
and honest album to date.
-Yeah.
Writing this album, I treated it
more like writing in my diary
than actually trying to put
together a song.
-Yeah, like putting together
a song, you mean like
when you're writing a song,
"oh, this is catchy
and this is gonna be a thing."
But this one, you're like,
"I just want to say this."
-I just want to talk about
how I really feel
and get more personal
with my hotties.
I feel like everybody knows me
and they have like a perception
of me based on probably what
other people say or what they
see on the Internet
or, you know, just --
It's something that's probably
not me at all.
And I feel like this time
around, I wanted to, like,
let everybody in my head
and, like, you know,
form their own opinion
based off of my story.
I wanted to take control of
my own narrative.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I think it's important
as an artist to do that.
-Yeah.
-Stretch yourself.
But I heard you on the radio
and I saw some video
the other day.
You were freestyling.
-Yes.
-Man, oh, man, can you rap.
-I mean, I might be
a good rapper or whatever.
-Yeah, "or whatever."
It was unbelievable.
And I freaked out.
"Yeah, show them how it's done."
-I might not have an Oscar,
you know.
-Oh, yeah, some people have
the Oscar.
-Some people have Oscars.
-Yeah, yeah, that's right.
-I'm gonna get one.
I'm coming for it.
-Yeah, of course you are.
I figure since "Traumazine" is
actually officially,
officially out right now, let's
do a little champagne toast.
-Whoo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This is a big deal.
-Okay.
-So here we go. Alright.
-You fancy.
-Should I do it?
-You got to shake it.
Just act like you in the club.
Yeah, pop the bottle, Jimmy.
-I know, but --
-Pop one, Jimmy. Give him
something to turn up to.
♪♪
-This is what I do in the club.
-This is what you do
in the club.
-Shake it up?
-Shake it up.
[ Rhythmic clapping ]
There you go. That way.
[ Cork pops ]
Whoo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Is everyone okay?
-You didn't do it good.
-Yes, I did.
-No, you didn't.
Let's make a mess.
Make a mess.
-What do you mean?
-You have to -- You should have
made a mess like this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Congratulations
on the new album.
"Traumazine" is officially out
now.
Natalia Dyer joins us
after the break.
Stick around, cheers.
Congratulations.
Dude, you are the greatest.
Come on!
♪♪